Demitri asks how do you prepare for an
important keynote Dmitry the way I
prepare for a keynote is to think about
punching every audience member directly
in the mouth I look at the audience as
my enemy yet my child there's this kind
of weird mix between loving them with
all my heart and really wanting them to
get the message there's a disrespect and
there's a love and that mix is what I do
I literally am like a boxer before
hitting the ring six minutes before I
take stage maybe that's where Jab Jab
Jab right hook came from in some ways
because I'm literally in this crazy zone
eight minutes before I'm talking I don't
even know that I'm giving a talk I'm
like just like do my email I'm just like
laughing I'm crying by the Jets like you
know whatever it is but around 6 minutes
zone I go into this weird place and I
get very focused and I say to myself
you're only as good as your last talk
and so even though I've had a great kind
of seven year public speaking career
none of that matters the second I take
that stage for the next time because
you're only as good as your last at-bat
and so my friend to answer your question
to be drink the way I prepare for a
speaking engagement is the same way I
would prepare for war